[Music]
hi I'd like to talk to you today about
distributed column stores and why we
built one so so my name's Sam Stokes and
I'm a boxer and a land conservationist
and also I'm an engineer at a small
start-up called honeycomb in San
Francisco and when I'm not making
software I'm usually found making
cocktails or sometimes bad jokes and I'd
like you to meet retriever
what is receiver well Retriever is a
distributed columnstore it's also an
analytic query engine and we have a
schema list data model and hang on let's
back up a bit because you're probably
wondering like why would someone build a
database it's pretty much rule number
one right of any company is that you
don't build your own database and if you
do you don't call it a database you call
it a data store so we got a data store a
big difference okay so Retriever is a
domain-specific data store handling you
know domain-specific language no one
should build their own language either
but sometimes there are particular
domains where it's useful to build some
abstractions and provide yourself with
some tools so to talk about retriever
being a domain-specific data store I
have to talk a bit about the reason that
we built it we built it to power
honeycomb so let me talk a bit about
honeycomb well you can think of
honeycomb was the company I work for as
a debugger for production and that's a
bit vague we want to help engineers
understand and troubleshoot distributed
systems which as you may be aware can be
kind of difficult to understand at times
and honeycomb sits in between metrics
and traditional log aggregation and
tools but that's a bit abstract so let
me make it a bit more concrete by
talking about how honeycomb works so the
basic idea is that your systems the ones
you want to understand that
they send us events events are otherwise
known as structured logs they're
otherwise known as globs of Jason here's
an example event you can see it's got a
bunch of different fields you know like
an endpoint and a host name and a status
code this is an event representing the
processing of an HTTP request so you
send us lots of these things we store
them we just store all the events that
we get in a way that lets us get them
back later you issue queries in a kind
of database like way so here we're
saying like for every endpoint in events
that I'm sending in calculate these two
things like response time and some other
thing and we turn your queries into
pretty graphs like this and there's a
lot going on in this graph so don't
worry too much this isn't the talk about
data visualization but suffice to say
that if any of you are fans of heat maps
for visualizing response time
distributions then come talk to me
afterwards because I get really excited
about it but let's give an example of
how you might use something like this
just to make it a bit clearer of what
problem we're trying to solve here so
let's say you run an app a web app and
one of your users sends you an email
saying hey I tried to use your app last
night I tried to upload a cat picture
and it didn't work and you're like great
didn't work what exactly does that mean
like users never tell you what's
actually wrong so you need to go and
find out what happened so you ask us to
draw a graph of errors over time so here
are you know here's a graph of error
rate and you see okay right well there
was an error spike you know around 2:30
a.m. that's about the time that the user
sent their email so I guess you know
we've confirmed there was a problem
great but why like what happened things
were fine and then they suddenly weren't
so the first thing you might think is
you know we've been doing this a while
when things go wrong it's usually
Amazon's fault so maybe one availability
zone went down or something you know
we're hosted we're doing best practices
were hosted across to ACS so let's break
down this graph by their ability zone in
order to see if there's any pattern
there and so we do that and we get this
graph and now we've got you know two
lines one for each zone but we
straightaway see that well this spike
was correlated in both zones it happened
at the same time about the same
magnitude so what is going on is not
specific to one zone it's just going on
across the board so green tick
everything's fine
though we haven't solved the problem so
we need to dig deeper so let's actually
look at the events that we use to
generate this graph these are the events
that your application sending us so
again we store all the events so you
might go in and you'd say well find me
all the all the events that showed an
error so we see they have all common
pointers going yeah we can see they all
have an error status code like 500 they
seem to be coming from a bunch of
different host names so there's no real
clue there but they do all seem to share
this one build ID in common you know
let's say that's the the build version
of the software that we're running so
you know haven't proved anything yet but
maybe there's something wrong with that
build that is causing this error so
let's go back to the graph
I'll try breaking down by build ID well
this shows pretty obviously that the
spike is coming from this new build that
we rolled out and maybe we noticed and
rolled it back or maybe it rolled itself
back or something but now we know pretty
much where the problem is you know we
still don't know what it is because I
haven't talked about the details of this
hypothetical software but you know we
can go check out this new build see what
changed fix the bug etc we might have
one more question which is like how many
people did this affect how bad was this
you know was it just one user that was
unlucky so we can ask one more question
tell me all of the distinct host names
in my cluster grouped by build IDs so in
other words how many servers did each
build exist on and so we can see here
like this bad build the orange line
rolled out to about 20% of our servers
and then we roll it back so the thing
wasn't so bad so we've gone from a
really vague report of like hey the cat
picture didn't upload to an idea of what
the what the problem was how to fix it
and we know what the impact was a few
more questions you might ask like which
customers were affected it's nice to
know percentage but if you can actually
find the exact people you can track them
down and you know reach out and say hey
we had a problem sorry about that maybe
more generally just like which of our
customers are seeing the most errors if
there's some poor customer who's like
can never use the app cause it's always
broken for them or even like root cause
analysis like which thing caused this
error in the first place maybe it was a
call to another service so these are the
kinds of questions that honeycomb China
is trying to help you answer cool so how
do we do that how can we answer these
sorts of questions well we pretty much
need to be able to store the data that
you're sending us and they give it back
to you well spoiler alert how we do that
is retriever what does the data store
look like that can process this kind of
workload well for a start we have a sort
of sequel like query model we have you
know operations like breakdown and
filter and the idea is you can break
down and filter by any property of the
data you don't have to predefined like
I'm gonna be able to break down by
hostname or by a endpoint but that's it
you can break down by anything you know
I did a breakdown by build ID there's
lots of things I could do and you can do
these breakdowns even if the fields have
high cardinality which is something that
some sort of traditional time series
products kind of struggle with so what
the hell does that mean
well you know build ID is one example
where if your software has been being
developed for awhile you might have
hundreds of different builds a more
interesting example break down by user
ID right the that example I gave of show
me how many users were affected by this
error or show me which users are seeing
the most error
that means you need to be able to break
down by a field where there might be a
million values you might have a million
user IDs so we need our queries to be
able to return raw events just give you
the events back and that's how you can
do that fine-grained analysis and we
also need to be able to return time
series because graphs are really helpful
for spotting patterns and we need to do
to create those time series we need sort
of operationally interesting
calculations the kind of things that are
useful for solving operational problems
like tell me the 95th percentile of this
thing that was going on you know 95th
percentile response time or a count
distinct it's pretty useful that's how I
did that how far is this build rolled
out kind of graph and we have to do all
of that really fast to go through that
example that I just gave you you know
trying one theory and then plotting a
graph and then finding that wasn't the
right theory and digging around for more
clues and trying a different theory and
eventually finding the answer if it took
me a minute to run each query then I'd
never get to the end of that process I'd
lose interest and make go make coffee or
something so we need the queries to come
back really quickly and finally we're a
start-up we have a really limited budget
and a very small team which means that
this has to be really simple it can't
look like this thing we aren't building
a general-purpose database we don't need
to do most of the things that a database
needs to do we have very specific access
patterns both for the data coming in and
for the kinds of queries you can run in
fact we control the only UI that can run
queries on this thing so we know exactly
what kinds of queries you can run and
that lets us optimize for very specific
access patterns rather than trying to be
general-purpose we don't need to be able
to update data in place once you've sent
us an event it happened you're not gonna
go back and say well I didn't actually
run that HTTP request and we don't need
to do some of the fancier features that
a real database would have like joins or
transactional semantics
so if we can make it simple we need it
to be course if for the rest of this
talk I'm gonna describe retriever I will
start off by sort of giving an overview
of what it looks like how it's designed
then I'll dive into the details of how
we store the events and how we get them
back some of the interesting details of
how we can speed up queries by
distributing them and finally finish off
by talking about some of the cool
operational properties that we get
because this is we're actually running
our own copy of this which means we have
to be able to do certain kinds of deal
with backups and failover and that sort
of thing
ok so let's start off with a very
high-level description of what the hell
this thing is
so it turns out that someone already
solved this problem so Facebook built a
system called Scooba and this is their
internal tool for solving exactly these
sorts of problems scuba is a distributed
event store meaning that you send them
huge numbers of events from lots of
different systems at once and they
ingest them and store them all and they
spread them out across many nodes I
think they have some huge number of
nodes in Facebook and they make sure
that queries are fast by taking the
queries and founding the mount also
across the nodes to where the data is
and then they make things even faster by
storing all the data just in RAM RAM is
really fast so scoober is awesome if you
talk to anyone at facebook who's used it
they'll pretty much universally agree
that they can't go back to a world that
doesn't have scoober in it because it's
just so good at answering questions but
it's a facebook internal tool which
means we can't use it
which means our customers can't use it
so we had to do something different so
Retriever is a distributed event store
inspired by scuba but we do things a
little bit differently and one of the
big things we do differently is that we
store data on disk and the reason we
store data on disk is pretty simple
we're not Facebook and we
don't have the infinite money cheat code
so Scooba stores everything in RAM but
it turns out that SSDs are actually
really fast as well particularly for
certain kinds of workloads and you can
get perfectly acceptable performance at
much less cost particularly if you're
storing stuff for many customers which
we are we use a column-oriented storage
model which I'll be talking more about
later in fact this is a great moment for
me to do a quick straw poll could you
put your hand up if you're familiar with
column-oriented storage already awesome
like 70% of the room could you also put
your hand up this will come in later if
you are familiar with Kafka about the
same maybe half the room and could you
keep your hand up if you're using
catherine production okay about 25
awesome yeah so we use something called
column-oriented storage the current
version of Scooba actually uses this as
well but at the time that they published
the paper about it they were using a
more traditional sort of row or inted
model or not come into all that putting
those two things together actually gives
us some pretty useful properties which
again I'll describe later we can lean on
the file system for a lot of the
semantics that we need from from the
datastore so we don't have to build them
ourselves file systems are like decades
old mature technology written by kernel
hackers and I'd much rather trust them
than any code that I wrote
similarly I'd much rather trust Kafka
than any code I wrote and so we trust
Kafka for a lot of stuff great so at an
enormously high level here's what
retriever looks like a customer sends us
data we write the data into Kafka we
have retriever nodes
running as consumers on the Kafka queue
they read off the data as it comes in
and store up to disk we have them
operating in pairs so we have
replication and we have character is
partitioned so we are storing events
across multiple nodes and then when we
need to read it customer issues our
query to our API
cat goes now out of the picture our API
talks to right t2 retriever retriever
process of the query hands it off to
some other nodes as it needs to and as
the read well that's ludicrously high
level so let's zoom in and talk about
how exactly we're actually storing this
data by the way this building is
column-oriented that's important I did
warn you about the bad jokes I'm sorry
okay so one of that data model the basic
sort of partitioning of a data model is
that our customers have one or more data
sets and that's just our terminology for
it's basically like a table in a
traditional database and so you might
have a data set for your web logs you
might have another data set for database
queries that you processed so data sets
are partitioned meaning we spread out
the data across multiple nodes and each
data set gets a number of partitions so
most data sets we are running have three
partitions some of them the largest ones
have up to 39 in our current system and
dataset data set partitions contain
events
what's an event well again it's just a
JSON blob pretty much here's an example
of a couple of events you can see these
two look pretty similar except one of
them's got an extra field so let's
switch to a sort of table based view for
reasons that will become apparent so
here's here's showing a number of events
you might have sent into our system and
so you'll notice that the schema is
pretty uneven here but effectively every
column in this table is not able so some
events have an error some don't most of
them have a path but we've almost got
two different types of event in here
we've got these requests looking events
with more structured data in there and
then we've got this one at the end which
just has a string message and as well as
not having a fixed schema this thing
could have a huge number of columns it's
not uncommon for us to have events with
200
columns in and that's sort of because
you have the scheming of property you
might send us well first of all you
might you might be tracking a lot of
information about even your HTTP
requests you might want to know how much
time that I spent processing this
there's a response time how much time
did my database been processing this
versus my view layer versus other things
you might want to track some application
specific things like which user was I
performing this request on behalf of or
how many results did I get back from the
database and the more you can pack in
the more useful queries you can run so
imagine this table potentially being
very very wide and there's a couple of
interesting features here so on the Left
we have this column called index and the
idea is that each event gets assigned
unique index when we see it and we also
have a field called timestamp which is
just when did the event happen and every
event is required to have a timestamp
and that comes in useful later so when
we're storing these we have a couple of
choices and I can a lot of this is gonna
be sort of recap'd for those of you who
are familiar with column oriented
storage already but I think it's worth
talking through an example of how it
works because it really brings home the
properties that we get out of out of
doing things this way
so we have to turn these things into a
stream of bytes one way or another so we
can either store we can either store an
event at a time or a row at a time or we
can do this other thing called column
oriented so a traditional row oriented
approach you just store all the fields
for a given record together so you get
one record coming in and you're right
you know the path and the response time
in the status and then nothing because
there was no error then another record
comes in and you store all the fields
another record comes in you store all
the fields and so on so the whole
dataset is effectively one long file you
might choose to chunk it into multiple
files for other reasons but that's the
basic idea and this is good for a lot of
things it's good especially if you're
mostly reading all of the data all of
the time but it does mean that if all
your interest
like the response times you have to skip
over a lot of data that you don't really
care about so another way we can do this
is by storing a column at a time and so
this is how retriever does it we have a
file for every column or column in the
table or a file for every field in the
events that you send in so how would we
store the same data in this format well
so here's a path file this path file
contains all of the values for the path
column so we get an event in we record
its path
in fact we record its index and then its
path we get another event we store the
index in the path
another event index path etc so this is
the whole path file and it doesn't
mention any other properties same idea
for response time we store all the
response times so what about the era
file because this is a column where
we're missing values well we get the
first event in it doesn't have an error
so we don't need to write anything and
I'm not saying we write an empty value
you know a null or a zero
we just don't write anything at all we
don't even create a file then the next
event comes in we need to write
something third event comes in again we
can just leave that file untouched so
imagine we had a hundred events and only
one of them had an error we only wrote
one thing to this file which means if
you're reading errors if you're
interested in counting how many things
had an error for example again you can
skip over reading a lot of nulls and I
talked about this special timestamp
column the reason this is useful is that
because it's always there we can use
this as our index that says what what
events exist in this data set because
the index is the unique value that got
assigned to every event and so we need
this to know what events do I even have
available to query so that was that's
sort of the general idea but to make it
a bit more concrete how do we read this
data well the first thing we need to do
is
we've got a query but we have all these
columns how do we how do we know what
columns we have available to query well
because things are stored as files that
just files sitting in a directory on
disk we can just say tell me what files
exist this is something that file
systems are pretty good at we don't
actually use LS but effectively we just
say show me all the files and this tells
us we have all these so let's say we're
running running the query give me the
average response time for events that
had status 200 so we check the files we
know we have these columns we look at
the query and we say what columns do we
actually care about for this query we
need the index column because we always
need the index to know what events there
are and we're going to need the status
column because that's what we're
filtering on and we're going to need the
response time column because that's what
we're calculating cool so we open all
those files and imagine this star is
like a file pointer so we read an index
from the index file okay we've got index
0 so now we're processing the event with
index 0 now we need to match our filter
so we read a value from the status file
until we hit the index that we got the
index that we're looking for in this
case it's index 0 and that's the first
thing we read so great now we check the
filter does it match well yes it does so
now we can read a value from the
response time column that we're actually
trying to calculate on we read until we
hit 0 here we go collect that value
we'll save it off somewhere that we can
do the calculation on it later and we
start again reading index read a status
file until we hit our next one check the
filter well this one doesn't match so
we're just going to skip over this event
so we don't need to read the response
time here so we just go straight back to
step 1 reading index index to read a
status file check the filter it matches
we're gonna read from the response time
file but this time we get the wrong
value we got the response time for index
1 which we skipped just now so we just
keep going until we hear index 2 great
we got it
collect the value and
we're done so that's how we read three
events very exciting but let's look at
what we didn't do so jumping back to the
table view and I've bolded all of the
data that we read which means the stuff
that isn't involved we didn't read in
fact we didn't even touch it we did not
open the path file at all we did not
open the error file imagine there were a
hundred columns that's a hundred columns
we didn't read that's 99% of the data we
didn't need to scan in order to answer
this query oh and there's this slogan of
only read what you need another
interesting thing we can do at read time
now that's pretty useful for our
analytic use case is we do something
called dynamic sampling and this is
something that's in the Facebook paper
as well so the interesting thing is that
you're sending us all this data and
we're storing it all and that's how we
get this flexibility but it can be
pretty expensive to just store
everything and not all of the events
that you send us are equally interesting
in particular most of the happy path
looks pretty similar if you're if the
requests happened you know it process
successfully and it process pretty
quickly you don't care that much about
it except to know that it's happening a
lot but you really do care about the
errors and the slow queries and the
things that looked weird so it's kind of
wasteful to store these successful
events that happen way more often
hopefully I hope you're successful
events are happening more often than
your own successful ones it's really
wasteful to store them all with the same
fidelity as you're storing the sort of
difficult cases that you actually want
to dig into so our dynamic sampling
means is we add this column to the data
model called sample rate and this is
another sort of special column and so
when you send us data you do sampling on
your side so you can say you know send
us send 1% of these events but
the dynamic part means rather than just
having a flat rule that says send 1% in
events you choose whether to send an
event or how frequently to send an event
depending on the properties in the event
and that's because if you just do a flat
sampling the problem you have is that
the interesting things you want to look
into the low probability events are more
likely to get dropped by the sampling
than the common ones and so you've sort
of shot yourself in the foot but if
instead you can look at the event you're
about to send and say this event looked
pretty good so I'm just gonna send 1% of
these but you know so that's the first
row in the table we've got a 200
response and a pretty fast response time
so this event was good we just send 1%
of these events the next one was an
error will descend every single error
and then the next event was successful
but it took kind of a long time know 600
milliseconds instead of 150 so maybe if
we go above some response time threshold
then we'll sample that maybe not as
heavily as we're sampling the good
events and you tell us the sample rate
so you tell us that decision that you
made and what you're really saying there
is this event that I'm sending
represents a hundred other events that
are like it what that gives us is the
ability to do calculations on the sample
data so we only store the sample stuff
but we can still calculate things like
how many events do we get for each
status so like if we're calculating that
we see that first out of 200 we had an
event come in with sample rate 100
another one with 20 so we had 120 of
those and one event at sample rate one
with an error and so even though we've
only stored three events we've actually
got the statistics 420 okay that's how
we read data from a single node but I
said that we speed things up by fanning
out queries so let's talk about that
so distributed query the idea is that a
client will pick a retrieve a node to
query the client knows which data set
it's querying and each data set is
assigned to certain partitions so the
client will just pick one of those nodes
that is consuming on them that partition
and send the query so we don't have like
a static structure of which nodes are
routes we just pick one and then the
route says okay I know that I'm not the
only node serving this query so I'd
better fan out the query to the other
nodes on the same partition then every
node is going to scan the rows that it
has in parallel and perform calculations
on the subset of the data that it has
then return the calculations back to the
root so it can do a merge of all that
data and send the query result back well
to make that actually work we have to
tackle the problem that the data is
partitioned which means each node only
has part of the answer and that means we
need to be a bit careful when we're
doing that combination step so there are
a lot of calculations where if you take
to the result of two partial
calculations and then do the calculation
again you don't get the right answer one
simple example being so you're computing
the average of these four numbers the
correct answer is two in a quarter but
if instead you had split these numbers
into you know one two and three and then
three well the average of three is three
the average of one two and three is two
the average of those two things is
two-and-a-half which is wrong so we
can't compute a partial average we can't
have the root the the leaf nodes compute
averages instead we have them compute
sums and counts so they just sum all the
values they have and count the number of
things they've processed and then they
send both the sum and the count back to
the root and sums and counts can be
combined in that way this is basically
commutativity this is a kind of thing
that comes up a lot in a lot of disputed
systems topics like if you've played
with CR DT is they require the same
property and so some other examples
besides average are if we're computing
things in groups
well our the way we store groups is
basically just you know an in-memory
hash of the group value to the
calculation that you're calculating
and you can merge these things just by
looking at all the keys in the group and
then merging the values we can do this
with you know count distinct find me the
unique values in this set to do that in
an exact way would be very memory
intensive so instead we use a data
structure called hyper log log which
lets us compute a probabilistic answer
to how many unique values are there in
this data set and it turns out that
hyper log log can be serialized in a way
that can be merged in a commutative way
similarly for percentiles there's a
similar trick called T digest and so we
can do all these calculations in a way
that we can fan out most of the
computation and then just merge it
together at the end one other thing we
have to deal with is we still have a
root node that's taking all of this data
and merging them together and so in some
cases this is going to be pretty memory
intensive for example if we were
computing a lot of groups we could have
a million groups coming back from each
node and we don't want the root node to
fall over because it's processing so
much more data than everyone else so we
can do the distribution trick again and
do a sort of n level fan-out again this
is something that scoober does they
experimented a bit and found a good
factor for how many nodes they should
allow fanning out to before they split
into another level of the tree if they
find that value is five we use the same
value so okay we can store data and we
can query it great we're done
shipping except that's not really all
there is to say because we also need
this thing to like work reliably we need
to make money from this thing so how do
we deal with that so I need to take a
quick detour through Kafka and I'm sure
I know but half the room is familiar
with this already so I'll try and skim
through this but I wanted to touch on
some of the properties that we use of
Kafka in order to get some of the
semantics that we need so we rely pretty
heavily on Kafka for a start as I showed
in that our
take diagram okay yeah architecture
diagram a while ago
it's how we get data in and that's
pretty nice because we didn't have to
write a high volume data ingest pipeline
we just like pulled one off the shelf
and Kafka also gives us the ability to
distribute rights to get replicated data
and a couple of other cool things so
what is Kafka well as many of you know
it's a distributed log it's not exactly
a message queue it's more like it takes
data that's coming in and just stores it
on disk in a write in a append-only
fashion the data model is that Kafka has
topics which are a bit like tables again
we publish messages into topics and
those topics are partitioned again
partitioning is the way that Kafka gets
horizontal scalability and within a
partition a behave properly that we rely
on is that messages are totally ordered
they come out in the same order they
went in and again cat crash he stores
the data on disk and this is really
useful because we can replay if we think
we missed data this is not unlike a sort
of standard message queue where often
it's just gonna route a message straight
from the publisher to the consumer and
maybe buffer stuff if there's no
consumer available calf could just
always store stuff on disk and so any
number of consumers can come along and
say hey just get me all the events since
since three hours ago so what does all
that mean well we get data in by
publishing events to a caf-co topic we
have as I said data sets are assigned to
partitions those are the same partitions
as the Kafka topic is split into so the
client is gonna pick which partition
it's writing to again it knows which
partitions that data set is supposed to
live on and right now we just partition
at random so the client picks one of the
partitions writes the event to that
partition random partitioning gives us a
nice even split of the data it publishes
it to Kafka we have a Retriever on that
partition consuming from Kafka and
writing to disk and in fact we have two
retrievers on every partition and that
just gives us replication for free
now every retriever or every every
partition has two retrievers consuming
the same data because we trust Kafka's
guarantee that messages are totally
ordered within a partition we can be
pretty sure that we're getting the same
data in the same order not necessarily
at the same time but eventual
consistency so one of the problems that
we need to solve is we don't actually
want to store all data forever we are a
business that makes money we charge
customers for storage so when a
customer's exceeded their quota we need
to be able to age out the older data
that they sent us and so what we do for
this is that as we're writing data we
split it up into segments segments are
effectively time slices of the data
stream coming in and so in fact when I
said that we assign a unique index to
every event in fact we do that per
segment so indices are unique within a
segment so we represent segments just by
directories on disk because we write
we're just writing data into files so we
can just split things up by having
different directories file systems
already have hierarchy built in when
we've written enough events we decide
okay this segments big enough it's time
for a new one we just create new
directory and start writing into the new
directory instead of the old one now the
old one because data is immutable the
old one we can just do what we like to
we can forget about it okay so if we
want to age out some data well we can
just scan all the directories that exist
again just ask the filesystem what
directories there are we can ask the
filesystem how much space each one takes
up and then we just have a background
job running you know it's literally just
a cron job that says find me the oldest
data that figure out how many of these
things I need to delete in order to
bring the customer back on the quota and
then it just asks the filesystem to
delete the data so there's all this data
management that we don't have to
implement ourselves
what about tolerating faults so
sometimes this process is going to go
down unfortunately nothing is perfect
sometimes we might deploy a bug
sometimes we might hit some weird case
that makes us crash we might have a
network outage we might just be straight
up deploying because we're actively
maintaining this we need to roll out
changes to it well we have to replicas
of each partitions so we have a copy of
the data so that's great
right we don't need to fix anything well
that's fine for query as we know we
always have a replica available for
querying but it's not quite good enough
because we still have new data coming in
all the time and if we shut down one of
our consumers well it's not processing
events while it's down obviously so to
recover from failures where I'm
including a deploy as a kind of failure
to recover from that each Retriever is
gonna track the offset that it's reached
in caf-co this is pretty standard for
any kafka consumer and because kefka is
guaranteeing that events are totally
ordered when we startup retriever we can
just say get me all the events since the
last one that I saw we trust the
ordering so so long as that value
written down is correct we can start up
from where we left off we consume
everything we know we're not consuming
duplicates so we'll take the incomplete
copy that we had and catch up and now
we're back up to normal but there's a
few more things we need to do and that's
because yep right
so every now and then we're gonna say
that we check pointed the data and the
reason for this is we're writing data to
multiple files that's the idea of the
column-oriented storage model so we
might be doing a bunch of writes and
then the process might die and it might
die in between writing for example the
path value into the path file and before
it got a chance to write the response
time value into the response time file
well that's a problem because we've now
written half an event we don't we
haven't fully written that event to disk
but we might have already written the
index file which says that event exists
and because we're treating these files
as append only we've sort of got a
problem where we're now inconsistent in
particular we might be inconsistent
between the two replicas so every now
and then we checkpoint we say up to this
point up to this event I am confident
that I've written everything fully and
so we store free check point we store
the caf got off set the pointer went in
in the calf gas stream at which that
event came in and we also store our own
index that's the incrementing value that
we assigned within a segment to each
event so the offset tells us to where we
can reconsider
index value to say this is the latest
event that I believe has been fully
written so when we start up we might get
the event coming in from Kafka and say
okay well this event is actually hang on
right let's let's check all of the files
that we've already written and say this
file
you know only goes up to the event that
we expected and that's fine but this
file has extra data in it you know we
wrote some extra values with an index
higher than the check pointed index in
other words we got ahead of ourselves in
those files so when we start up as well
as reckon seaming from Kafka we also
just take all the files we've written
and truncate them to the last known good
index and what we're doing there is
we're saying we can't be sure exactly
what happened with those files some of
them are ahead some of them aren't it's
hard for us to tell
afterwards so instead let's just treat
all of that data past this known good
index as suspect and just forget about
it and then Rican seam from that point
so we're not reprocessing any data that
we've written because we've just dropped
off all of that data and that means that
means now we can Rican we can restart
Retriever at any time even if it was in
the middle of a write and we know that
it's going to pick up from where it left
off and not be double counting events if
it happens to go back too far so that's
almost good enough we can handle process
failures but sometimes you know just
stuff happens in AWS sometimes a node
can just go away completely and that's
where we're storing the data we're
storing the nature on disks on the node
so we do need to handle that case well
if we need to bring up a new node to
replacer we can find another node on the
same partition because we have two
replicas and copy the data over from the
existing node onto the new one that
we're bringing up and again because
these are just files in directories on
disk we literally just use our sync to
do the copy our sync is pretty good at
comparing to directory trees and
figuring out what's missing and copying
them across in an efficient way and cool
now we have a copy of the data that was
on the other node but we might be out of
date because we still haven't started
consuming but the good news is when we
copy over the data we also copied over
the checkpoint file so that tells us
where to start again from in the Kafka
queue so we we our sync over to get a
snapshot then we start consuming caf-co
from that point and now again we're up
to date and now we have two healthy
replicas again so we get all of these
nice operational properties that we need
to rely on without having written very
much code we have replication and fault
tolerance via Kafka we have quota
management just by file system
operations and we can bring up new nose
again using leaning pretty heavily on
Kafka and I think
so that's retriever that's as simple a
database as we could write sorry
datastore then write a database that
gives us the primitives we need to run
it in production but keeps things simple
and the things I'd like you to remember
from this talk well first start calamari
to storage as you already know it's
pretty cool you can't you only read what
you need it can be a very compact way of
storing some kinds of data and you can
get very efficient performance for some
kinds of workload if you need to solve
distributed systems problems consider
not solving them but instead just using
Kafka to solve them for you if you need
to solve data management problems
consider not solving them file systems
are pretty great they have atomic
operations they have really intelligent
caching they have nice synchronization
operations but that's all another way of
saying sometimes it's okay to solve hard
problems but don't do that until you've
looked really hard for ways to make them
easy
and I'll be around for questions and I
think there'll be an office hours
section in after the coffee break as
well
I think we can do one question and then
we should go to coffee break
hi in one of the examples you had a
version in the event and there was an
integer
I said don't have updates so let's say
that right now my applications using
like one two three four five office
let's say okay now I want like same
verse same version a semantic versioning
like 1.2.3 now how do I go back or make
it this ballad I'm I'm not sure I
understood that we had a version in the
event one of the camps you had there was
like path build ID that kind of thing
uh-huh so let's say that is my
application version and I'll say that's
an integer today but tomorrow it's not
an integer anymore oh I see so you're
asking what happens if the type of a
field changes right so one of the nice
things about making so few assumptions
as we make is that we can sort of handle
fields changing type we can you know you
at one point you're writing the version
as an integer and we'll write it to file
it we write it to disk as an integer
file but if you start sending us strings
well we can detect that and say okay
we'll just or two files so everything
you sent us as an integer will stay that
way everything you sent us as a string
we'll create a new file alongside it
then at read time we can open both files
and do the appropriate merge and all of
that that's kind of messy but that only
lasts for as long as a segment does
because as soon as we roll the segment
over hopefully you're you're now writing
only strings and then you know we're in
a nice stringy world from there on and
we can we can do coercion at read time
so you know if you give us a query that
doesn't make sense for your old type or
like the need let's say you what you for
some reason you are asking us the
average version well that'll stop
working as soon as you start sending us
strings but we can always coerce a
string to a number I think we just you
know make it equal to zero
or something so it's not gonna blow us
up you're just you're gonna get as as
meaningful an answer as the data you
sent in
[Music]